And how does this tie into your work?
>> So one of the things that my colleague and I have been working on, is a whole
entire book that actually attends to the role of technology in couple and
family relationships. Because even though there's been a ton of research in the
field of communication in the field of of technology and cyber technologies and
digital stuff. There has been very little research in the field that looks at
relationships in the context of technology. And technology in the context of
relationships. So what we did was write a book called The Couple and Family
Technology Framework Intimate Relationships in a Digital Age. And what we did
was we synthesized what little research there is in the field of relationships
and technology. And then all of those other disciplines. Put it into one book.
And we really try to get people to think about things like the role of
technology in your sexual relationships with each other. is being friends, on a
social networking site, for example, with an ex, is that okay? Is it not okay?
is just chatting with people infidelitous? Is watching pornography a form of
infidelity? When is the appropriate age for children to get cell phones. when
should they be on social networking sites? Should they be playing games? How
will that influence them? How do we make sure that our kids have access to
comprehensive sex education. That we can monitor while blocking sites that we
don't want them to have access to because its not age appropriate yet. So, all
of these things are things that are really emerging. Couples, families,
individuals are experiencing them, but there's been very little written about
it and not really a comprehensive way for people to look at it. And so our hope
is that our book is going to be really a big step in in a beginning of of
really this revolution of this field of couple and family technology.
>> Now if you're interested in learning more about any of these topics, which I
highly suggest you do, check out Dr Markie Blumer's website or the book she
co-authored. Check out the instructor's notes section, where you'll find links
to information about Dr Blumer.